it's not it what it's about like there's
a certain standard in society for women
of how we should be and we're kind of
like taught that not saying it's verbal
right that's pushed on us on us from
it's okay it's a form of priming like I
have a teammate that I play volleyball
with her mother would not let her leave
the house without her nails done her
hair done and an outfit and if I [ __ ]
with her I would be inside every day but
it's because she said no man is gonna
want you because you don't look the part
and but that's it okay but if that's if
that's the if that's the case why are
statistically the majority of women
overweight like if that's the case if
we're forced to look a certain way right
and that's the standard right that's the
like standard then like I don't and men
don't accept there's a lot of things
that go into being overweight and if we
go back to what we talked about first
about toxic relationship and just like
just stuff that we go through
emotionally I think that women I'm not
saying that men don't go through things
emotionally but I feel like women go
through more emotionally and have things
right well we're more more emotional
yeah yeah yeah and from that the the
easiest thing to resort to is eating and
just being
um well they changed our food to comfort
from the 50s yeah and so I think that
that may be the one the main thing is
just like it's just Comfort finding
comfort and food food's always gonna
comfort you no matter what
and I think that that is one thing not
canceling out like men don't go through
nothing and we all yeah yeah right but
it's just like that's one thing from
just what I've seen and what I've just
like so you think the majority of like
women being overweight is from emotional
like trauma
all right let me can I just say
something yeah like
growing up I was a stick like I was
stick then I was underweight I got put
on medication to gain weight because I
was unhealthily underweight right and so
I and when I was skinny it was like all
I wanted to do was have curbs like all I
wanted was to have an ass like that's
all I could think about I gained weight
and then it's like the the whole it's
like the opposite right and it's like I
always felt like I was trying to fit
into a standard and it was like to never
fit into I could never just be because
but it's also that's personal on me
because it's like well it's interesting
because I would look at you like as the
like you you're stunning to be honest
like like that's what I'm saying this
but it's interesting because like you
you I feel like you have to know you're
hotter than like most girls
like you respect but like as so being
six three right like growing up I was
[ __ ] bullied because I hit six three
when I was 13.
have you ever watched that like those
movies oh those are the worst but like
but like I feel it like literally it's
funny when you say like LeBron James
because like when I was in Middle School
like people would be like oh Kobe Bryant
LeBron James
Sasquatch and it's like that has an
effect on you and like people would
always make comments to me like I was
like 120 pounds and I was 6'3 like I was
a [ __ ] twins yeah like
it was gross like I looked like a
skeleton right and then it's like all I
wanted was this one it was the curves
yes but you showed me pictures you were
curvy yeah okay to a point yeah like I
gained a lot of muscle right but then I
got on medication right gained a lot of
weight and then I was like well do you
do you feel like that's society or
that's like an internal it's internal
yeah it's a society right because
because Society is either like you're
either a good curvy or you're like
there's a nasty person but it's
interesting skinny and there's bad but
it's interesting because I like to me
it's all like like I think women are
meaner to women than men are to be
honest yeah
but also the part where women are more
critical comes from their insecurities
and oh yeah projection projection yeah
I'm in our very general but it doesn't
yeah I know but it doesn't make it okay
what you meant by that like women are
meaner to women like most guys aren't
you know like men swipe on right on like
50 of women like most men aren't that
most most don't say most men aren't that
picky like the also
[Applause]
they're attracted to like like a lot of
women like it's if you're getting
rejected by guys they're in a very small
percentage of men like 10 to 15 percent
of men even like they say
um 20 of men have access to 80 of the
women so the reason that we hate men is
because we're all effing the same ones
yeah like if you want a guy that's six
foot is in the top 15 amount literally
yeah you add income yeah yeah and so I'm
saying the majority of men aren't picky
and so so women because we're competing
for those men like they they tear at
each other we belittle each other
from example like
okay personally yeah never say there's
not a man that I've wanted that I
haven't got personally yeah let them
know let them know must be nice but yeah
there's been men that I've rejected that
have been like well I don't want your
fat ass anyways oh yeah oh yeah I'm
saying so it's like but like that [ __ ]
like sticks with you like you know yeah
it's like but you wanted me but now you
calling me this why are you feeling so
hard
yeah and try to try to make it one at a
time just so like the I've just had
comments that they can't hear because
there's too many people talking yeah
yeah I get what you're saying okay but
like you know like that [ __ ] is like six
with a person right like like I remember
there was one time I was at Cal Berkeley
and this guy was hollering at me and I
was like please [ __ ] off like he was
such a like little frat boy he's like
well I don't want your fat ass anyways
this was four years ago I was skinnier
then I was like 15 pounds lighter than
like I you know what I'm saying yeah but
like that [ __ ] like six with a person
like well he thought I was fat like so
it's like well but girls do like I don't
know girls kind of like are worse almost
behind each other's back well that's
true it's just not to our face one more
we're more behind the back that part is
[ __ ] yeah even in front of their face
girls are very spies but it's it's more
sub like we are shady you know men men
can't even see the looks that girls give
us at the bar and you know exactly what
looks like the the shade men can't see
it because
um there's a biological reasoning behind
it but basically like because women were
like gatherers and like we were more
with the kids biologically we pick up on
other people's emotions better so it's
I don't know but I do have oh yeah go
ahead go ahead a question what
and this might just be like a preference
or whatever but what is the cutoff
between because nowadays being big is is
not frowned upon at all it's work not
worship but it's glorified but when does
it come a point where it's like you're
thick and then you're too big like
I think it's your body shape to be
honest because you said the statistic is
a lot of women I want to say well the
average woman is a hundred and is five
five 155 pounds which is like 20 pounds
overweight something like that yeah
[Music]
but like the average woman I I don't
know the exact statistic off the top of
my head but she is overweight yeah
like if you went to a doctor like he
would say yeah I mean people can say
whatever they want like I'm a curvy like
curvier girl like but women like I know
personally like I gained a lot of weight
in my hips like like
some girls carry it better than others I
know like there's a like for her like
like genetically women carry more body
fat yes right
I tend to gain weight in my hips and
like my birthing area right like that's
where I carry my way so that's all like
it's they're like you know what I'm you
get what I'm saying so it's like there's
like
part yes like but it's all up to
preference like what are you into right
you know right so it's like what really
it like now well but they're talking
like stick that I think Kirby ways big
ass well I think the problem is when we
look at the guys that have all the
options to pick from they all seem to
pick the models
so that says something and the guys and
the guys and the guys name one
billionaire That's not married to a
model or or even married for like six
seven years and then they get a divorce
and is that what your goal is not all
Bill Gates Jeff Bezos both of their
wives are married 20 plus years they did
get a divorce yeah I'm sorry Bill Gates
wife is not that pretty and same she was
she was well yeah because but that's
that's because they got them young men
Value white and white men tend to like
thinner women well they they got them
young before they were even rich